yesterday i reported to you that the
united states would be banning russian
oil imports and within hours of that the
u.s did indeed ban russian oil imports
and it did again
send oil prices up and we are continuing
to see nominally record gas prices and
we may soon see
inflation-adjusted record gas prices
we're not there yet but i will let you
know when we do get there yesterday a
joe biden made a public statement
announcing the sanctions but in addition
joe biden said during his statement
um
russia's not going to take ukraine
putin's not going to win and of course
many people liked hearing this but it
also raises questions about well how far
is joe biden willing to go
to make sure that that's the case that's
the question we'll discuss in a moment
here's joe biden yesterday
that'll mean tyrants like putin won't be
able to use fossil fuels as weapons
against other nations
and it will make america a world leader
manufacturing and exporting clean energy
technology of the future to countries
all around the world
this is the goal we should be racing
toward
over the last two weeks the ukrainian
people have inspired the world and i
mean that in a literal sense they've
inspired the world with their bravery
their patriotism their defiant
determination to live free
putin's war putin's war has caused
enormous suffering and needless loss of
life
of women children everyone in ukraine
both ukraine and i might add russians
ukrainian leaders as well as leaders
around the world have repeatedly called
for a ceasefire
for humanitarian relief
for real diplomacy but putin seems
determined to continue on his murderous
path no matter the cost
putin's now targeting cities and has
been targeting cities and civilians
schools hospitals apartment buildings
last week he attacked the largest
nuclear power plant in europe with an
apparent disregard for the potential of
triggering a nuclear meltdown
he has already turned two million
ukrainians into refugees
russia may continue to grind out its
advance at a horrible price
but this much is already clear
ukraine will never be a victory for
putin
so of course we all want to believe well
most of us maybe the guy i'm going to
play a clip of next doesn't but most of
us want to believe that that's the case
that this you can't do what putin has
done
and win and get away with it and annex
or take over ukraine or install a puppet
government or whatever the case may be
the question is
can joe biden really be sure of that
without ever committing u.s troops to
ukraine now from the beginning i've said
i don't want u.s troops going to ukraine
and joe biden has said u.s troops will
not go to ukraine there's no question
about that i'm not changing that or
arguing against that
the question is
is joe biden in a position to guarantee
that vladimir putin will not take
ukraine
and at the same time be sure that that
is possible
without even potentially committing
troops to the fight i don't know the
answer to that it's sort of an empirical
question about the military power
and what nato is potentially willing to
do now of course there's this in between
right where
the u.s is part of nato
and is there some
technically accurate scenario
in which the us
doesn't send troops to ukraine
in a direct sense
but does
through nato if nato chooses to enter
and then it becomes
it's almost like a semantic question
right is are those u.s troops because
they're fighting under nato or not it
becomes a semantic question but
the question remains
how can joe biden really ensure putin
doesn't win
without being willing to send troops and
is that militarily
logical uh and i don't have the answer
there's different opinions about that
depending on what military analyst's
opinions uh you you follow
one other clip i want to play for you as
i did mention yesterday joe biden
announcing the ban on russian oil and
gas imports
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
this is a move that has strong
bipartisan support for congress and i
believe in the country
have rallied support have rallied to
support the ukrainian people and made it
clear we will not be part of subsidizing
putin's war
this made we made this decision in close
consultation with our allies and our
partners around the world particularly
in europe because a united response to
putin's aggression has been my
overriding focus to keep
all nato and all of the eu and our
allies totally united
so the question about what will happen
with gas prices is a real question as i
have said to many of you before you know
i i don't play political games with this
stuff okay as i've said to you before
when gas prices are up 12 cents
and republicans go crazy and say this is
our death knell in an attack on the
middle class we do the math and we look
at the average number of miles driven by
the average person
and what we're talking about over the
period of a month from a 12 cent
increase in gas prices is a few bucks
okay and for most people it doesn't make
a real difference in terms of their
budget
we are now talking about something
different we are now talking about gas
already averaging i believe it was
yesterday was 419 a gallon i think now
we're up to 429 a gallon
uh and could be going up to 520 it's a
we are now talking about significantly
more expensive gas that will start
having an impact on many people's
monthly budgets because of
trucking expenses also increasing it
will have trickle-down impact on
products that people are buying now what
is there any upside the upside is
that after i mean listen at this point
it's probably been
close to a month of increasing crude oil
prices
as of right now as of this moment of me
recording today's show
crude oil prices are down five percent
and what this could be is that well
everything that can be done has
basically been done
and the crude oil market is essentially
a futures market it reflects what do we
expect about the supply of oil in the
future
and we've seen the price of crude oil
continually go up
as expectations for supply crunches are
priced in
as we hear announcements about what's
going to be done we may and these could
i might end up eating my hat when crude
oil gets to 150 or 200 bucks per barrel
we hit 124 yesterday we're now down to
117.
it's conceivable that the uncertainty
has all now been priced in we just don't
know and uh again that's just based on
what's going on literally as of this
moment with crude oil down five percent
so the announcement is made
and uh
we it it is a serious thing
and it is a global issue it is not joe
biden's fault as i explained to you
yesterday
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded number one best overall
mattress for the last two years by both
gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand every
helix mattress comes with a 10 year
warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video